let's talk about those tax returns okay
I received a few emails from the
audience during our vacation and it's an
interesting question why hasn't anybody
hacked Donald Trump's tax returns by now
at this point is very clear that there
are endless reasons why seeing Trump's
tracks at tax returns would be relevant
and and of interest to millions of
people even before the election uh
number of polls were done which said
Madrid that a majority of Americans want
to see Donald Trump's tax returns we we
now have added to that the known
conflict of interest through Donald
Trump's businesses the growing and
disturbing friendship with Russia and
praise of Vladimir Putin
we have FBI and CIA opinion that Russia
hacked the election to help Donald Trump
it's more important than ever to see
what is in Donald Trump's tax return so
we can just figure out for ourselves
once and for all what is the
relationship between Donald Trump his
businesses Russia and Vladimir Putin now
to be clear I'm not an advocate for
anybody doing anything illegal right I
and I is important for me to be clear
about that isn't it that I'm not going
out there like Trump did and saying hey
maybe action hack why that's not what
I'm doing yeah I get that I mean illegal
actions I think can be Noble in some
instances as long as they're nonviolent
and for the interest of the American
public we're not encouraging anyone to
do that exactly right at least Pat knows
that that's not what I'm doing because I
will get emails from people saying David
why are you advocating the hacking of
Donald Trump's tax returns what I am
trying to explore is why hasn't anybody
hacked them by now well it hasn't been
WikiLeaks it hasn't been anonymous and
nobody has hacked the Trump tax returns
back in August as far as WikiLeaks is
concerned Julian Assange said WikiLeaks
isn't trying to hack the Trump tax
returns we we've since learned more uh
that might explain why WikiLeaks was not
trying to hack the Trump tax returns but
I don't think we can expect WikiLeaks to
participate as far as anybody else
there's a combination of reasons to
explore this we have to figure out first
well who could you hack the tax returns
from where could you get the tax returns
we have of course the IRS as a
possibility the federal tax agency of
the United States another one is the
date agency in Trump's case New York
state's tax department uh presumably
from Trump's accountants or maybe
Trump's lawyer as far as the IRS is
concerned there's a former IRS agent
named Richard Schickel who told The
Washington Post a few months ago that
there are probably tens of thousands of
people who could access Donald Trump's
tax returns with nothing more than his
social security number
that being said why wouldn't someone do
it you would think someone who would
have the the means to do it would want
to do it because they might see
themselves as potential heroes well
number one it is a felony so there's
huge risk for any IRS employee who might
want to do it number two if you access
the records there is a trail of that
there is a record of you having access
those tax returns so the idea that you
could do it and nobody would know it was
you if you handed off to media or
something like that not really true
and number three it's not totally clear
that media outlets would be uh uh able
to avoid legal action if they merely
republish something that they didn't
hack when we are taught generally you
would think well media outlets would be
protected by the First Amendment they
didn't do the hacking if they get
Trump's tax returns they could publish
them that is actually debated by legal
experts if you go ahead as a media
outlet and republish something like tax
returns the First Amendment may not
cover you so this might explain some of
why we haven't yet seen these documents
I mean everyone could just wait until
the IRS audit is over with because
Donald Trump is word that he would
release his tax returns once that was
through yeah I can just wait oh yeah
years couple months any day now that's
gonna all wrap up and Trump's gonna
release those tax returns uh so let's
forget about the IRS and your state
employees for for a bit what about a
hacking group less clear what about
hacking Trump's accountant well
accounting firms usually have pretty
good security are there people in these
big hacking consortiums like anonymous
who have the know-how I am sure but uh
sometimes the security that accounting
firms use is after returns have been
filed they keep only paper records
multiple copies of course in case
there's a fire
kind of theft but only paper records
also the data might be on file with a
lender that Donald Trump received alone
from at some point that'd be another
possible place it's an interesting idea
also that's been floating around in a
friend of mine mention this over the
over the a break what about putting
together a bounty for Trump's tax
returns uh you could absolutely raise
five hundred thousand even a million
dollars to anybody who who uh finds and
publishes Trump's tax returns so I don't
know the answer Pat as to why nobody's
hacked the Trump tax returns for now I
know that there is huge interest in
doing it we also know that there are
significant significant penalties for
getting involved in that type of action
uh do you think we will eventually see
those returns I mean you were kidding
before with the hole as soon as the
audits over we'll get up from Trump but
is this something you expect to ever see
I doubt it because once the IRS audit is
over he'll just come up with the new
excuse that he's not running for
president anymore and there's no reason
to he's already acting within the
interest of the American public to that
point I tend to agree
I believe that unless the documents are
subpoenaed for some uh proceedings that
could be you know use your imagination
what they might be or that these tax
returns are elicit Li hacked I do not
believe we will ever see Donald Trump's
tax returns and as a result although we
can speculate a lot about the insane
conflicts of interest that exist with
Trump and not just Russia we've exposed
but the Philippines we've exposed a
number of other conflicts I don't know
that we will ever definitively know
about exactly what is going on there
send me your thoughts about this I'm on
Twitter at D Pakman the David Pakman
show is on Twitter at David Pakman show
we will take a break
we are back it's 2017 only 17 days from
the inauguration of president-elect
Donald Trump and exactly 17 days remain
in our fundraiser at david pakman.com
slash donate check that out plenty more
after this today's show is brought to
you by go daddy where you can buy your
own domain name build a website or use
any of Go Daddy's business tools you can
save 30 percent at Tri godaddy.com slash
David
Oh daddy has actually been the official
host of the David Pakman show website
for many many many years the 24/7
customer support has been a very good
thing for us I've called them at really
odd times when we we've had website
issues and they are always available
they are the largest domain registrar
and whether you have a new idea you're
an established business you're creating
a personal website or moving your large
enterprise site over to GoDaddy they can
do it all thirteen million customers try
it and get 30% off at try go daddy.com
slash David